now to the desperate efforts to free a
group of missionaries who are being held
for ransom in haiti fbi agents are
working with local authorities to find
the 16 americans and one canadian who
were kidnapped on saturday the wall
street journal says a haitian gang now
wants 17 million dollars for their
release that's a million dollars each
for every victim this abduction happened
just outside the capital city of
port-au-prince manuel bajorkas is there
with more on the story manuel good
morning to you
good morning gail haiti's justice
minister is the one saying that the gang
is demanding one million dollars each
for the release of those 17 missionaries
that's according to that wall street
journal report a source close to the
gang told us
that the kidnapped children are growing
increasingly frustrated crying and
refusing to eat
haitians took to the streets of
port-au-prince monday to protest their
government's response to the country's
multiple crises including a surge in
violent kidnappings a deadly earthquake
and the assassination of their president
this comes days after authorities
believe a violent gang known as 400
mawoso abducted 17 missionaries from an
ohio-based christian aid organization
there is so much frustration in the
streets here these haitians come out
pretty much every day to protest the
dire political and economic situation
and the poverty creates a fertile
breeding ground for the gangs so many
young men without jobs who can be easily
recruited
a family of five from oceana michigan is
among the americans kidnapped todd
dueling is the pastor at a local church
there to have it hit that close to home
is extremely heartbreaking
but what about the other families linda
works with children in haiti she asks we
not mention her last name for fear of
retaliation she says the children have a
special prayer before leaving the house
mommy linda please pray
that we will be invisible
and so that when we walk the streets we
won't be taken
and yet they are
meanwhile fbi tactical teams are in
port-au-prince assisting with
negotiating the safe return of the
american and canadian missionaries james
gagliano is a former special agent with
the fbi's hostage rescue team you're
trying to do two things at the same time
maintain open lines of communication and
prepare for the worst if god forbid you
know hostages are being killed or
they're threatening to execute hostages
that you do have an assault team that
you have information is is close enough
that you can place them to actually do
conduct a rescue
just to underscore the poverty at the
root of all of this linda told us that
when her organization in the past has
had to negotiate with the gangs here
the number one thing they ask for
is food
tony
manuel horcas for us in port-au-prince
manny thank you very much please stay
safe